today we are trying somewhat 2016's
weirdest makeup trends nice Battlement
so a lot of people say the 2016 was a
really shitty year so we're gonna try
some shitty shitty beauty trends I love
the trendsetter sort Instagram I think
they make some really incredible things
so we're gonna try them out you know get
a male perspective cuz that's what
everybody wants press the lips have fun
I love this one because it's all about
fancy rock so crystal lips are a thing
where you make your lips look like geode
love geodes i love crystals so i can't
wait to have them in my mouth i think
i'm gonna go for an amethyst look it's
my favorite go2 ruby geode cuz it's red
blue you know so what do you do you
gloss your lip and I'm very good at
makeup that in your language ha it's a
lip gloss and I'm gonna mix it with some
glitter glamour okay here we go oh I am
already loving this look I know it's
vivid okay I'll clean it up in a second
no you know I watched the tutorial I
don't think the other guys really paid
much attention now looks like I have a
soul patch I'm not gonna just write it
all over the place I think this is good
for this level it's not just about
glitter it's about I do look like glows
oh don't I
where does it look like I went down on a
mermaid the last thing is we'll use a
lip liner to outline it very much like a
geode being cut open em I had pink lotus
a double whammy otherworldly or
flip-flop who knows really
both whop yeah I'm a football yeah yeah
looks like we have some shitty lip
liners here that will not work because
they're too opaque just can't be the
desired look cuz in the vlogs you see
them use this really awesome powder you
can see it here also it reminds me of
rocks this is wrong this is wrong I just
it's not working look like a like a
disco king also kind of looking like a
tan and go but who wouldn't like oh my
god a new blaze who wouldn't like throw
eight bars on my shirt oMG Oh fabulous
what it's supposed to be a [ __ ] Rock
to be a rock I'm drooling now that's
supposed to be a gem that you break open
like when you're ten you're like wow Oh
instead it just like a man who went to
Buffalo Wild Wings and ate a coaster so
those are crystal lips Harmon bulb
borehole up next is fur nail which is
where you cut out fabric from your mom's
closet and you glue it to your hands I
picked a cheetah and I will be your prey
when I'm cold in the winter you know
what's the coldest oh my do you ever
have a Lucky Rabbit any rabbit's foot
yes no I had a looking for a dude your
fingernails are huge
that's so weird look at your [ __ ]
fingernails I mean you could probably
kill like a small puppy for furn else
which can't make a coat which I curled
the vil should have thought about okay I
would not want to have sex with these is
this where I say it looks like you
fingered a skunk I'm sorry I'm engaged
those days are over no I think would be
a great [ __ ] the lips make me really
sad you know I'm not I'm feeling pretty
happy Ferb ulis night liner it was a
Halloween friend and it you make your
eyes look like they're bleeding because
that you got fur your nails you want to
cut your eyes out one of us needs to
start on the black handle of the knife
on the top the other could start with
the red blood underneath yeah finding
your island okay so just easy does it no
Asians are very used to knives to the
eyelids okay double eyelid surgery
because an Asian reference black no
don't spit dammit oh gee this is a great
way to cover up baggy eyelids big woman
being a woman's heart enough all right I
don't been hard being woman you shut the
[ __ ] up you shut the [ __ ] up I'm a [ __ ]
you can't step out wow your your your
eye looks really thank you
handles looking really good UI I tried
to make it thick hey your outlines of
the tears of blood looking really good
pretty good beauty can draw inspiration
from anywhere and I think the trends
from this year prove that know one thing
I know them we probably look better than
Zack and Keith [ __ ] it all makeup should
make you happy and if if it's making you
mad then what's the point these trends
are pretty 2016 right we're just trying
to distract ourselves from what's going
on in the world be like Oh what if I
paint a knife on my hide yeah sixteen is
so bad what am i mouth of 2016 subscribe
this year has been a lot there's been
some register like yeah name one thing
Taylor Swift didn't put on an album
[Music]